hola muy bienvenidos a la entrevista de
france 24 en español en esta oportunidad
nos acompaña rafael mariano gross y él
es el director general del organismo
internacional de energía atómica oiea
perteneciente a la organización de
naciones unidas y que está encargado de
monitorear el uso pacífico de este tipo
de energía a nivel mundial
rafael grossi es uno de los mayores
expertos mundiales en temas de energía
atómica señor gross y muchísimas gracias
por su presencia en la entrevista de
france 24 es un placer
un placer también para mí estar con
ustedes bueno señor gross y comencemos
despejando algunas dudas no y quizás
cierta desinformación incluso prejuicios
que existen en el imaginario colectivo
no respecto de la energía nuclear se la
suele asociar a bombas guerras a
carreras armamentísticas a programas
secretos no de parte de algunos países
con objetivos aún más secretos etcétera
pero la energía el nook nuclear
proporciona acceso a energía limpia
fiable asequible no incluso suelen
mitigar efectos del cambio climático la
clave está en su uso verdad
absolutamente usted lo ha dicho si la
ciencia la tecnología nuclear tiene
distintas vertientes por un lado la
propia generación de energía que como
usted dice la energía nuclear es una
energía considerada limpia porque
prácticamente no tiene emisiones de co2
y en ese sentido no pues no contribuye a
los efectos deletéreos del cambio
climático sino que por el contrario
aporta una solución al mismo también la
ciencia la tecnología y las aplicaciones
nucleares son útiles en la medicina
nuclear en la seguridad alimentaria en
una cantidad de elementos estamos
trabajando en este momento en el control
de la pandemia del 19 es decir hay una
cantidad de dimensiones que son muchas
veces ignoradas por el gran público de
lo que es la ciencia la tecnología de
las aplicaciones nucleares y la energía
nuclear también es cierto que
de energía nuclear y la fisión del átomo
puede ser utilizada para con fines
bélicos y de destrucción y esa es una de
las importantes razones de ser del oiea
porque nosotros a través de un complejo
sistema internacional de inspecciones y
monitoreo controlamos que aquellos
estados que desarrollan actividades en
el campo nuclear que por lo tanto poseen
materiales nucleares que podrían ser
susceptibles de usos militares no lo
hagan usted asumió el cargo señor rafael
en diciembre de 2019 con varios desafíos
no por delante entre los más nombrados o
por lo menos entre los que tienen más
presencia no en las agendas mediáticas
está el plan nuclear de irán no y el
supuesto incumplimiento de lo acordado
en el pacto nuclear de 2015 del cual ya
le preguntaré un poco más adelante
precisamente viajó usted recientemente a
esta nación islámica cuenta y no por
supuesto hasta donde pueda por supuesto
el objetivo de este viaje
y como resultó
efectivamente el programa nuclear de
irán es objeto de control y verificación
por parte de la guía desde hace varios
años y en el último tiempo esto ha
continuado y existió un acuerdo
importante entre cinco potencias más uno
en el año 2015 un acuerdo para controlar
el programa nuclear de irán verificado
por el oía y esto a digamos dado lugar a
una intensa actividad de control por
parte nuestra por parte de la guía en
irán últimamente y desde hace algunos
meses nos habíamos encontrado con
ciertas dificultades en el cumplimiento
por parte de irán de sus obligaciones en
materia de dar acceso a los inspectores
del oiea a ciertos lugares que habíamos
solicitado visitar nos encontrábamos en
cierto
en un impass
y por lo tanto decidí también merced a
la invitación del gobierno iraní
trasladarme a teherán para negociar
directamente con el gobierno iraní y
tratar de desbloquear esta situación
para permitir la regularización de
nuestro proceso de inspecciones y la
vuelta el acceso de nuestros inspectores
a ciertas instalaciones importantes
sensitivas en la república islámica
estuve allí unos días y afortunadamente
y luego de un complejo proceso de
consultas y negociaciones entre la
secretaria que yo dirijo y las
autoridades iraníes y luego de
entrevistas con el ministro de
relaciones exteriores sharif con el
presidente rugani y con las autoridades
técnicas nucleares logramos por así
decirlo destrabar esta situación tener
un acuerdo y nuestros inspectores han
reanudado sus actividades
ahora además de ir a rafael yo sí con
que otras preocupaciones o desafíos
asumió usted no la dirección del
organismo trascendió recientemente que
existe cierta preocupación por
actividades en corea del norte
bueno corea del norte es un caso
paradigmático porque nunca estos
inspectores fueron expulsados de corea
del norte en el año 2009 quiere decir
que tenemos más de 10 años de ausencia
en ese lugar como usted sabe corea del
norte ha desarrollado un arsenal nuclear
y por lo tanto es imperativo el regreso
de los inspectores del oiea
nuestra ausencia física no significa o
no implica que la agencia nos siga de
manera minuciosa y detallada todo lo que
está ocurriendo allí a través de
informaciones de inteligencia y del
propio análisis de nuestros expertos
tenemos una imagen relativamente
completa de lo que allí está sucediendo
estamos por supuesto a la merced de leh
el avance de las negociaciones que por
ejemplo en este momento están siendo
llevados a cabo entre los eeuu y la
república popular y democrática de corea
cuando se llega a un acuerdo en el
momento que esto ocurra cuando esto
ocurra el oiea va a ser el indispensable
inspectora do que va a controlar que los
términos de ese acuerdo político se
cumplan en la realidad por lo tanto es
un uno de los temas más importantes que
tenemos en materia de no proliferación
pero como usted bien señalaba nuestra
agencia tiene un programa muy vasto y
que tiene que ver también con la
seguridad de los reactores nucleares con
la consideración y el tratamiento de
cuestiones común en la situación en
japón luego del accidente de fukushima y
otras tantas ahora él hoy ya tiene
varios objetivos no entre ellos como
decíamos en algún momento esta
entrevista el de garantizar un uso
responsable pacífico y también eficiente
de la tecnología nuclear pero debe
lidiar no con países que están inmersos
en conflictos en tensiones se me ocurre
irán versos eeuu irán también diciendo
que israel la sages los servicios de
inteligencia de israel le aportan
información al organismo moscú moscú en
tensiones con washington ahora el uso de
esta energía está entonces atravesado
por la política y por cuestiones
lógica no claramente en este sentido
como trabaja el organismo no que por un
lado imagino debe mantener cierta
neutralidad pero tampoco escapa de estas
tensiones de tipo político ideológico
absolutamente en su pregunta hay muchos
elementos de mi respuesta
el oiea es un organismo internacional
imparcial técnico y que tiene una misión
indispensable que es la de proveer una
evaluación técnica como decía recién
neutral e imparcial de lo que realmente
está sucediendo en el terreno en el país
que está inspeccionando como es obvio y
natural en el medio de estas tensiones
geoestratégicas y políticas que usted
también ha descripto existen presiones
existen interpretaciones existen
aspiraciones de que el oiea vaya en un
sentido o en el otro y nuestra misión es
caminar derecho
y proveer esta imparcialidad esta
neutralidad técnica que solamente un
inspector hado internacional puede
proveer y que es tan importante porque
cuando se hacen acusaciones o se tienen
sospechas
o certezas todo esto en el terreno
nuclear tiene que ser comprobado tiene
que ser probado y la única manera de
hacerlo es a través de una tarea por así
decirlo de auditoría internacional que
solamente puede aportar el oiea por lo
tanto si debemos atravesar un campos
minados de tensiones y de aspiraciones
en poo en pugna pero para esto existimos
hablemos ahora del acuerdo nuclear
firmado en 2015 no entre irán y seis
potencias hablamos de eeuu rusia china
reino unido francia y alemania que
contemplaban no levantar sanciones
económicas a irán a cambio de que
limitar a este país su programa de
tecnología nuclear y ciertos puntos de
vigilancia a posibles incumplimientos
entre otros temas en 2018 eeuu se retiró
de este acuerdo cuáles soy el estado del
acuerdo considera que en este nuevo
contexto sería necesaria alguna
modificación o un nuevo acuerdo
bueno el acuerdo tal como fue firmado en
el año 2015 tuvo o atravesó una serie de
avatares entre los cuales se cuenta el
retiro unilateral por parte de los eeuu
en el año 2018 y posteriormente como
respuesta a esa medida una serie de
restricciones o de auto restricciones
por parte de irán a las disposiciones de
este acuerdo sin embargo es importante
subrayar que mientras todo esto ocurría
el oiea siguió y sigue
inspeccionando y comprobando el
cumplimiento y también el no
cumplimiento de algunas de estas metas
de control del programa nuclear iraní
que fueron acordadas por lo tanto
nuestra tarea si bien no somos un actor
político
en esta situación coyuntural que se está
dando
somos un factor indispensable de la
ecuación porque somos los que
comprobamos lo que realmente está
sucediendo allí nuestra tarea no es la
de pronunciarnos acerca de la
conveniencia o no de un acuerdo esto es
algo que queda en manos de la política
estatal es decir los países decidirán si
les parece bien un tipo de acuerdo u
otro nosotros lo que le damos a ese
acuerdo es la credibilidad de que está
siendo cumplido al pie de la letra hoy
por hoy de votar que yo no me
pronunciaría o no sería correcto que me
pronunciara como director general del
oiea acerca de si él
jaycee pioli es bueno o es malo nosotros
verificamos que se cumpla y es
importante que cualquier acuerdo se ha
observado en todas sus disposiciones
está claro que he visto los avatares y
las tensiones que existen en este
momento existe por un lado una
interpretación que considera que el
acuerdo es insuficiente y por otro lado
los otros participantes del acuerdo
consideran que el acuerdo debe ser
preservado indudablemente va a tener que
haber en algún momento un punto de
encuentro y de convergencia para que
este acuerdo sea viable a futuro porque
en el estado en el que está se encuentra
severamente cuestionado nosotros sin
embargo no nos pronunciamos sobre el
fondo y seguimos cumpliendo nuestra
tarea técnica de verificación
-mariano bros y muchísimas gracias por
su presencia en la entrevista de france
24 ha sido un placer realmente el placer
ha sido mío no gracias a usted ya
nuestra audiencia como siempre le
invitamos a continuar informándose en el
resto de nuestra programación y en
france24 punto com
[Música]
bien